[Music]
the question is can they find those
margins can they find that opening so
far TSM has outmaneuvered seven no quick
silver sash he is down is shut down what
is equally apparent this team is gone
liquid
[Music]
yeah I'm sorry
so then from recent history especially
in a name
everyone kind of DC sucks he didn't find
the success he thought he would in North
America he wanted to be the very first
player to win both Europe and North
America yeah he didn't really the first
Nexus turn is coming in clutches highs
but second year that they will miss it
the bottom operating out of his seat I'm
sorry I apologize because I've been
having worse as a player as a person
these last year's I had to be the one
that stood up and carried both outside
the game in the game I didn't in the
offseason TSM didn't want to renew my
contract
so I know that offers a had from a name
and me you an excerpt of the IC and LCS
I thought about display flapper Scrabble
to kill oh and a shirt fire man
immortals just lost three and spam
counted them all up spin follows up on
it's an torrents just trying to hobble
out that is a four for one cloud nine
did lose their truth right now cloud
nine look unbeatable and to call them
the best team in North America
well that would be an under state law
dine they use the herald properly and
they're gonna crab first turret they're
a pleasure to watch right now like I
really like seeing like what a team is
identified as an optimal strategy and
them to just go through it perfectly
they're the first in the league with his
van playing like he's the best ad carry
in North America I think this event is
really good I think svenne is actually
maybe the best I've ever seen him in the
best form I've ever seen him in LCS
he looks unstoppable with cloud nine
fans cheering him on every chance they
get but just a few months ago those same
fans were pissed off cloud and I and
signed him in the first
place the roster changes soft for
everybody I think the person who got the
worst out of this entire situation I
think is Ben where he joined a team
because they asked him to join and he
just got like flamed for it and he just
he didn't do anything he wasn't a part
of the team
he wasn't even one of the people who
gave feedback to leadership he just
joined the team and then started getting
flamed for it which really sucks so the
guy was coming off a terrible two-year
stint with TSM he went from being one of
the best ad carry's in the world to a
complete mean thanks to a colossal throw
at the LCS finals what is the objective
that we have fighting for hey did he die
try to get the [ __ ] spire control-y
rek sai's Balt Lane what are we doing
it's safe to say that his stock in the
Pro League of Legends ecosystem felt
hard oh you heard this narrative oh my
god dude Sven is so bad I mean he just
plays so bad it's crazy I don't know
like if I got to e2 killed by Sven or if
I got ganked by the Joe Aaron died I
know the game is absolutely the same as
before I die nothing is gonna change I'm
still gonna pressure him in Lane I'm
still going to be more useful later and
he's still going to randomly die no
matter what and for those who've only
watched his van in na it's easy to
forget that he was once arguably the
best ad carry in Europe g2 eSports get
themselves another kill for the first
time in history be fourth consecutive EU
LCS title g2 eSports are the best team
in Europe
given another chance on a top teams van
needed to prove that he was worthy of
the opportunity so he spent the
offseason working harder than everyone
else he even went to Korea before cloud9
boot camp to relentlessly grind with his
new support Vulcan I mean wait a final
games in two months and we didn't do
anything every day except for like play
solo queue and eat but it was good for
like our team bonding I guess as a duo
and as a team I think it helped a lot we
think I see at this game specifically
but we will that practice paid up with
c9 sitting at the top of the standings
but no matter how many games ven grinded
dis offseason he couldn't have done it
alone I really feel like this c9 is one
of the best teams I've like played
against Racine that just their entire
team is so insane so aggressive and they
just never really seem to miss their
opportunities when he got his start an
origins Ben was a rookie looking to
prove himself along veteran stars now
almost five years later it's Ben's the
veteran looking to prove that he's still
worthy of being called an all-star I
think I'm not a leader in name I don't
suck ball but outside of the game in our
reviews in our postgame talks I have a
lot of things to say about the game how
the help must be there next time and
make sure next time in the 10 situation
we could be better
Sven's proven that he was once the best
in the west now let's see if he can do
it again thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages